i've said this before but i really
believe our show has the greatest
fans in the world our fans are
incredibly funny and creative
as they've demonstrated again and again
over the years that's why tonight
i'm very excited to announce we are
asking our fans to produce an
entire episode of our show that we're
calling
do it yourself conan
[Music]
it's the perfect project to help get you
through these pandemic times
i mean why waste time learning another
language or how to
paint or play the piano or figure out a
way to stop global warming
when you can spend your time creating an
episode
of conan here's how do-it-yourself conan
will work
we're going to post a special conan
episode online
your job is to pick one or more clips
from that episode and recreate them from
scratch
the only rule be creative let your
imaginations run
wild we did this a few years ago it was
a huge hit
here are just a few examples from that
show
[Music]
really amazing in fact i'm not sure why
we never switched to an all animated
robots format i really don't know
just to whet your appetite one of the
clips you'll get to recreate
is the now famous moment our associate
producer jordan schlansky said
then i prepared my body in various ways
i cleaned it shaved it
that's right now you'll get the chance
to recreate jordan schlansky in various
ways
so again have fun be as creative as you
can be while of course
following all the current pandemic rules
for staying safe and healthy
then we'll take our favorite entries sew
them together into one incredible
program
which will air during our regular time
slot in the fall
diy conan is being brought to you by
snickers
and thanks to our sponsor there are some
incredible prizes you can win including
i'm sure it's just a coincidence
probably
a year's supply of snickers you didn't
see that coming did ya
cha-ching so go to teamcoco.com
diy conan for all the details
you